STEPHANIE WONG: This
week, we're talking
about protecting sensitive
data, choosing the right cloud
architecture, and KubeCon 2019.
I'm Stephanie, and welcome to
"This Week in Cloud," where
we serve you the
lowest latency news.
Cloud data loss prevention is
a powerful service that brought
state-of-the-art data protection
to a variety of workloads
and storage formats.
And now, it's even better
with an easy-to-use UI,
making those capabilities
available to your security,
compliance, and legal teams.
Learn more about
scanning your data,
setting up regular monitoring,
and identifying trends.
No terminal required.
Speaking of sensitive
data, it's time
to revisit best practices
for password management.
October is famous for being
National Cybersecurity
Awareness Month.
While it can be fun to dress up
as someone else for Halloween,
it's a lot less fun when someone
dresses up like your bank
account.
So, in honor of
the holiday, Google
released two white papers
discussing modern password
security for users and
for system designers.
Happy holiday reading.
One size fits most is
not a policy we believe
works for cloud solutions.
That's why Google Cloud
offers a variety of products
in many configurations.
If you find yourself
caught between Compute
Engine and Kubernetes
Engine, you're not alone.
We've created two
architecture training paths
so that you can learn more about
virtual machines, containers,
and make the best
choice for you.
And, speaking of Kubernetes,
KubeCon and CloudNativeCon 2019
is happening November 18 to the
21st in San Diego, California.
If you want to learn more about
cloud solutions of all sorts,
you should come.
Register online today or
on site at the conference.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Have any thoughts or ideas?
Leave us a comment or tweet us.
We'll see you in the cloud.